What did it say?
The voicemail?
Doesn't matter.
It was ages ago.
Matters to me.
It was something like…
"Hi, Maeve.
I'm watching you on TV
right now.
And I wanted to let you
know how proud I am…
of you.
And about how you saying
you had feelings for me
was all I ever wanted
to hear.
Cos it's always been you.
I love you."
Anyway, it was stupid.
Did you mean it?
Of course I meant it.
I can't… I can't do this.
Okay.
I understand.
I don't… I don't
wanna lose you again.
I'm confused.
This is confusing me.
Wake up!
Are you okay?
What happened?
You fainted.
Okay.
Yeah. Give me your hand.
And the other one too.
Come on.
Come on, you got this.
There you go.
And you're up.
Okay, now do you want me
to call someone?
Get you some water?
No, I'm okay.
You sure?
Oh my God.
Oh my God!
Oh, okay.
Hey!
Stop that!
Two more laps for you,
Covey.
-Thank you.
-Wait… wow.
I…
Lara Jean.
I had a lot of fun tonight.
-Yeah, me too.
-Yeah.
Dude, you're blowing it.
You're blowing it.
Okay.
Hey, Vivian.
Vivian, wait, wait.
No. Look, it's fine, okay?
I was just confused.
You don't have to…
run out of your car
about it.
I like you.
A lot. I do.
I don't know. I got
all in my head about it.
You know,
I started worrying that
maybe I shouldn't
come off too strong.
You know, you're like this
super powerful feminist and…
you're not just a cute girl.
I mean, you are a cute girl,
don't get me wrong.
-Okay.
-All right.
-So--
-I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry. It was…
I
didn't think properly about
what I was doing and...
It was a stupid thing to do.
I don't want you to feel
awkward about it.
-It was all my fault.
-Charlie, hang on.
I shouldn't have kissed you.
I bet you just
felt pressured to do it
because I asked,
and you probably don't want
to talk to me every again,
but I at least
had to say sorry.
See if maybe
there's a chance
-we can still be friends?
-Charlie.
I don't want to lose you.
-I did something stupid.
-Charlie.
Give me your jacket.
Oh, okay.
I want to see
if you can just
react to what I do.
Oh, I don't remember
signing up
for a dance lesson tonight.
You're really gonna
turn down a free lesson
from the best dancer
in the state?
Oh, I would never.
Do you know him?
Is he coming or…?
Okay.
You don't have to be
in control all the time.
You're not studying
for a midterm, all right?
You can't think your way
through this.
Quinn, you gotta…
let your body drive you.
Okay.
Show me what to do.
So how's your knee?
I read this article
in The New England…
Oh, sorry!
Sorry. Oh, muscles!
Sorry. Okay. Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Sorry, I know that you were
probably expecting Olivia,
so we don't have
to do anything
if you don't want to.
Truth be told, I've never
kissed anyone before.
It's not that
I haven't wanted to,
don't get me wrong.
For example, I punched Ron
Getler in the sixth grade
during Seven Minutes
in Heaven.
Sophomore year,
Spring Fling,
I was dancing
with Randy Melrose.
You know,
a romantic song came on,
I was like, "Oh, it's gonna
happen!" But… until…
It just didn't 'cause--
This isn't so bad.
Not so bad at all.
Wait!
There…
Everyone… everyone
just saw that, didn't they?
Yup.
I'm not…
I'm not-- Hey, wait!
I'm not-- Sorry, I'm not…
Why didn't you tell me
the real reason
you got that black eye?
It didn't seem important.
Okay, but you…
you, like, defended
my honour
and you took a punch for me.
Yeah, well…
Yeah, well,
I guess I did that.
What?
Nothing.
I'm just making
some mental revisions
to my perfect boyfriend
checklist.
Well, did I make it
over 50%?
Way over.
But, you know,
the only major
sticking point
is the milk crate.
I really don't get
why you don't just
put your stuff in a backpack
like a normal person.
Well, because,
I knew the day would come
where I would need it,
and I wanted to be ready.
Ready for what?
For this.